sie selbst gm
warum nicht weil ich noch ein
kinderwunsch habe ich bin total gegnerin
irgendwann vom impfen ja warum
ich finde das ist noch nicht alles
nachgewiesen und welche nebenwirkungen
davor kommen sind sie gegen korona
geimpft nein warum nicht ich habe mir
die grippeschutzimpfung geholt und das
genügt da die angst vor der impfung oder
von dem stoff größer als die von der
erkrankung
ja auf jeden fall
mitten im thüringer schiefergebirge
liegt die kleine kurstadt bad lobenstein
knapp 6000 menschen leben hier gerade
mal die hälfte von ihnen ist gehen wir
wollen wissen warum das so ist und hören
uns erstmal auf dem wochenmarkt um
meinen freundeskreis haben sich noch
nicht viel impfen ich weiß noch nicht
warum aber regen sich auch wenn sie nur
getränke aber das ist ja dann schon ein
thema bei ihnen und was sagen die wenn
sie fragen warum macht er das nicht
können sie nicht einfach irgendwie
spritzen werden wollen haben wieso
wirst was mutter von nebenwirkungen
kriegt
man denkt manchmal das kann doch gar
nicht sein dass das man so dagegen ist
oder es wird es sehr viel positives
davon berichtet ich weiß es ich bin
nicht geimpft nein
ich habe auch davor angst auch ganz
ehrlich
ja weil man das enthüllt wie viele dann
auch danach sterben daran und wir im
endeffekt jeder an sich selber gerne
ja ich denke mehr an meine kinder meine
familie aber die kinder würden sie ja
auch schützen wenn sie geimpft
ich sage mal so alle alle reiter sag ich
mal impfungen da bin ich einverstanden
sind
das jahre alle getestet und auch
nebenwirkungen sind klar und was davor
kommen kann aber
jetzt das neueste was so auch schneller
impfung gefunden gefunden wurde das ist
mir wissen alles zu riskant rätsel noch
immer warum die leute nicht obwohl
zugaben der eigenen verwandtschaft sogar
leute dabei sein es ist schön zu laufen
was sagen die warum sie das machen ja es
wurde nicht helfen aber ich sag doch mal
wieder so aber sie werden halt nicht so
stark infiziert und das so schlimm wie
im krankenhaus dann liegen und
vielleicht sogar sterben aber es geht in
manchen köpfen halten stehen jedenfalls
jetzt noch nicht sie selbst gehen nein
warum ich weil ich noch ein kinderwunsch
habe und ich mir da von den forschungen
doch zu wenig versprechen also man weiß
ja immer nicht so richtig mit die
langzeitstudien das fehlt mir einfach
noch besser um die sicherheit sorgen zu
können
weiter sind ja millionen menschen auf
der welt gekämpft und das ist
nachgewiesen dass man trotzdem schwanger
werden kann warum machen sie sich dann
trotzdem immer noch sorgen er weiß die
ganzen sage jetzt mal
verschwörungstheorien mit den den auf
änderungen und so gibt und das ist mir
einfach die langzeitstudie noch jetzt
ist er da der sich jetzt sagen kann ich
vertraue dem 100 prozent sie sagen ja
selbst verschwörungstheorien ja gibt's
ja der triba zerreden da gibt es wie
sand am meer hat es gibt aber glaube ich
bezüglich bei jedem thema aber glauben
sie denen trotzdem ich bin da eigentlich
ziemlich treu also ich lebe mein leben
einfach weiter ohne den kopf zu machen
ängste und verschwörungstheorien die
erwiesen falsch und offenbar trotzdem
nicht aus den köpfen vieler zu verbannen
sind warum das gerade hier so extrem ist
fragen wir auch den bürgermeister sein
amtssitz direkt am marktplatz
in der region saale orla kreis ist die
impfbereitschaft die impfquote sehr
niedrig und nur bei 50 prozent was weit
unter dem deutschen schnitt liegt wie
können sie sich das erklären
gut eine plausible erklärung dafür habe
ich eigentlich nicht wird dann hier bei
ihnen genug gemacht für die aufklärung
haben sie da eigentlich
aufklärungskampagnen beteiligt und
irgendwann
aufklärungskampagnen als solche sind die
anderen reichlichen über die medien über
die gesundheitsministerien über den
landkreis vom gesundheitsamt gemacht
worden wir haben broschüren ihre bei uns
in der stadt auslegen jeden tag stets in
der zeitung drin
ich weiß nicht was ich sie jetzt sonst
noch machen kann die 2g regel hält er
eher für ein problem
als eine lösung das volk wird vor allen
dingen dadurch gespalten dass man den
geimpften vehemente vorteile einräumen
die dürfen ungeachtet irgendwelche von
weiteren kontrollen in der gaststätte
gehen können die maske abnehmen dürfen
sich im freien raum ohne maske bewegen
wenn jugendveranstaltung sind ist zweig
regel das heißt ich muss geimpft sein
wenn ich diese veranstaltung besuchen
will ja die anderen müssen einfach
draußen bleiben er selbst sei auch in
skeptisch und setzte vor allem auf
schnelltests der bessere weg für mich
ist eine tagaktuelle testungen auch eine
testung vor der veranstaltung dann kann
ich relativ sicher sein dass die
teilnehmer dort sauber rein gehen in die
veranstaltung und das risiko einer
ansteckung gering bleibt doch auch tests
sind nur eine momentaufnahme und jeder
test kostet geld in der örtlichen therme
herrscht 3g wenn nicht geimpft oder
genesen ist kann vor ort für drei euro
einen test kaufen
ist das noch vertretbar oder wie sehen
sie das dass sie extra für die test
anzahl müssen weil die nicht geimpft
sind mit gut
weil wir heute ausgeschlossen als nicht
geimpfter von der ganzen bevölkerung
alles nicht schön ist okay also ich sage
mal wenn es jetzt auch im rahmen ist das
ist jetzt ich glaube drei euro sind das
hat sich hier dann ist es okay
während zwei locker und zwar die therme
jeweils monate lang geschlossen das
heilbad musste herbe verluste hinnehmen
deshalb hoffen sie hier dass sie nicht
noch mal schließen müssen das aktuell
die infektionszahlen wieder steigen
besorgt auch manch ungeimpften besucher
größer sind aber ihre zweifel an der
impfung
ich habe bedenken
ich habe mehrere fälle in der familie
die beschwerden hinterher hatten bei der
impfung ich habe es einfach noch ein
bisschen raus gezögert mein mann ist
geimpft und ich vielleicht muss ich es
auch immer noch machen auch was bin ich
ganz davon überzeugt dann würde jetzt
nur noch elf durchbrüche die
geimpften liegen im krankenhaus
geimpftes hin gestorben also was nützt
dann diese impfung und dann lasse ich
mir dieses gift rein spritzen und dann
sterbe ich vielleicht an der impfung
also wenn es dort im stoffe gibt ja aber
jetzt mit dieser m rna auf keinen fall
gerüchte über angebliche im folgen kennt
hausärztin kathrin frühjahr aus ihrer
täglichen praxis
sie sind durch gesprächen mit anderen
nachbarn
oft verunsichert es gibt also
gerüchte die runde machen aus welchen
quellen diese speisen ist es mir
unbekannt dass patienten in großem maße
impfnebenwirkungen haben dass leute
sterben in höherem maße und was ich in
keinster weise bestätigen kann zurzeit
hört sie immer wieder solche geschichten
jeder einzelne versucht sie dann
aufzuklären und den menschen ihre ängste
zu nehmen ich habe gerade heute noch
einmal mehr patienten gehabt die
wirklich zu einer hochrisikogruppe
gehört hat im und aggression ist stark
übergewichtig und
sie ist nicht bereit gewesen bisher sich
impfen zu lassen weil sie von den
nachbarn
gruselgeschichten darüber gehört hat
kathrin frühjahr führt eine von zwei
hausarztpraxen in denen in bad
lobenstein geimpft wird allerdings sind
hier alle impftermine bis dezember
ausgebucht wer sich zeitiger schützen
will steht vor einer logistischen
herausforderung die zentrale impfstelle
für den salon kreis ist im krankenhaus
pößneck eingerichtet hat die anfahrt
strecke von lobenstein bis nach pößneck
an das krankenhaus war mindestens über
eine dreiviertelstunde das ist nicht für
alle organisierbar auch hier hören wir
von beschwerlichen wegen zum impfen und
mangelnder aufklärung den wirtsleuten im
hotel schwarzer adler ist schon vieles
zu ohren gekommen was sie verunsichert
hat
die machen wir vom mit wissen sie warum
gebraut gezapft getrunken
immerhin ihren humor haben sie nicht
verloren auch wenn seit monaten kaum
noch gäste kommen
woran liegt das dass hier in der region
eben leute dich weniger leute geimpft
sind als anderswo in deutschland ja ich
weiß auch das kabinett würde das weiß
ich allerdings konnten setzte ich kann
werdet rede wir müssen sowohl die herren
der jene die marke diskutiert schon
arbeiten hätte halbjahr mit die herren
da hinten sind heute die ersten gäste
hier sitzen für die freien wähler im
stadtrat und auch sie können nur
spekulieren
es gibt oft schwach sind und das wird
halt nur die sozialen medien verbreitet
und das ist so ein thema was von den
jungen leuten ausgeht und da am junge
leute den zugriff darauf
aber die leute überall in deutschland
endlich gleichen also da fragt man sich
warum sind dann die leute ich das dann
eher glauben als woanders
das kann ich mir auch nicht erklären
sind halt nicht alle gleich und deren
reaktion die auch noch nicht enthalten
von der seit
1018 wir sind ich will nicht sagen
gebrannt die kinder aber es kommt halt
immer noch aus ddr zeiten kommt noch
irgendwas rüber wo wir immer sehr sehr
vorsichtig sind und wo wir doch erstmal
abwarten dieses und jenes müssen wir uns
erst einloggen
unterschiedliche generationen
unterschiedliche gründe für die in
skepsis doch an der alleine liege es
auch nicht ich habe nirgends bei irgend
einen zettel gross gesehen wo drinsteht
welcher arzt impfen vielleicht
fehlt auch wirklich an und transparent
sei selber mit landratsamt
gesundheitsamt in der teilweise
überfordert gewesen es sind
wahrscheinlich gerade auch wieder weiß
momentan ziemlich hoch geht aber die
müssen sich dann trotzdem irgendwo mal
ein fahrer machen wie kann ich denn die
leute mobilisieren aber die leute die
wollen vielleicht impfen gehen aber
haben keine möglichkeit ich bin zum
beispiel nach kiel gefahren zum impfen
das sind ungefähr 80 kilometer und
ich stellte das zweite mal dort zum
impfen partner hat meine erziehung
gesagt sie macht in seoul mit da ist es
erledigt aber dadurch dass das so weit
auseinander ist kartoffelland sachen
viele leute wie soll ich dir nach gera
können wie soll ich das oder jenes
veranstalten da lieber lasse ich mich
erstmal nicht impfen impfen oder nicht
impfen auch wert hin und werd sind noch
hin und hergerissen welche weiß nicht
was man machen soll das ist richtig
das ist schon alles in ordnung und wer
hat es auch macht finde ich gut weil wir
sind einfach noch nicht so weit
so wie viele hier in und um bad
lobenstein die wir auf unserer spuren
zurück getroffen und die uns ihre gründe
für die impfskepsis geschildert haben
von sorgen vor angeblichen im folgen
gerüchten und verschwörungstheorien die
meisten ein vor allem eines ihre
verunsicherung